abro mi curso en mudo del instituto de
estudios políticos de burdeos y así
tengo acceso a la clase pregrabada
instituciones políticas francesas a sus
18 años y vos nunca ha puesto un pie en
una filial las conferencias para él son
así
sí
[Música]
y voy regresa regularmente a la casa de
sus padres aquí en parís esta
alternancia le permite romper la
monotonía de su vida cotidiana
a menudo me encierro en mi cuarto y la
mayoría de las veces tomo mis clases en
zoom a diferencia de los estudiantes de
secundaria de clases preparatorias o de
carrera técnica y bono tiene clases
presenciales desde el segundo
confinamiento es una decisión difícil de
entender para su madre creo que los
jóvenes necesitan estar juntos para
evolucionar en sus vidas no es con sus
padres ese no es el objetivo se pierden
creo que pierden un año de sus vidas
días antes en el macro acababa de
anunciar el regreso de los estudiantes
un día a la semana a la universidad pero
para ello no es suficiente especialmente
porque el joven se siente estigmatizado
hay personas que critican pero no saben
qué es tener nuestra edad sí tuvieron
nuestra edad pero no en la misma época
no volvimos a clase y ahora sienten
lástima por nosotros porque hay
estudiantes que desafortunadamente se
suicidan o entran en depresión y ahora
por fin se interesan por nosotros
después de cinco meses en aislamiento
hola feliz cumpleaños comparte su
indignación con su amigas así a pesar de
su sonrisa la joven sufre por la falta
de interacción intenten solicitar el
servicio psicológico de mi escuela está
saturado desde hace un mes así que no
dio frutos pero sí personalmente estoy
hiper ansioso estamos acostumbrados a
trabajar y luego notamos que ya no lo
logramos que nos dejamos tomar pensaba
que no tenemos más motivación para mí
personalmente es muy duro estos
sentimientos martín lo siente a veces
también estudiante del primer año de
terapia del lenguaje en lille también
pasa sus días en su habitación
mi cama mi escritorio hay un baño
pequeño con un lavamanos y aquí la
cafetera para aguantar gracias al café
es un estimulante necesario para
afrontar las largas obras frente al
computador
la neurociencia es un tema muy tenso en
el que hay mucha información y es cierto
que cuando no entendemos y cuando
tenemos dolor de cabeza es difícil
manejar la fatiga va creciendo así que
tuve que rehacer mi botiquín he estado
contando muchos analgésicos últimamente
aunque no suelo usarlos
para tomar un poco de aire fresco martín
sale regularmente al parque de la casa
donde alquila su habitación trato de
tomar descansos entre las clases en
videoconferencia para relajarme pero el
aparente ambiente ideal de vida no lo es
todo
todavía hay encierro todavía en
preocupación por las condiciones de
trabajo y estudio estamos en un sector
que normalmente requiere la adquisición
no solo de conocimientos técnicos sino
también de habilidades interpersonales y
por lo tanto de contacto con los demás y
es cierto que somos una promoción que
casi no ha tenido contacto martínez
presidente de la asociación de
estudiantes de su campo de estudio y se
considera afortunado a pesar de todo a
su alrededor ve a muchos jóvenes a la
deriva y no solo por la falta de vida
social por supuesto que los estudiantes
necesitan salir es un escape pero la
mayoría de los estudiantes el 95% o más
están preocupados por su escolaridad su
futuro y lo que están construyendo
el futuro es lo que hace que óscar siga
adelante
como suele ocurrir los miércoles por la
noche vino a abastecerse durante la
distribución semanal de ayuda
alimentaria en el campus
villa cebo máximo
estudiante de la escuela de ingeniería
oscar está luchando para llegar a fin de
mes su trabajo apenas se permite pagar
los 581 euros de su alquiler
encontré bananos y yogur eso es muy útil
[Música]
si bien se piensa en un afecto
y no es el único que necesita esa ayuda
normalmente tenemos alrededor de 200 250
estudiantes y ahora esperamos más de 300
esa situación precaria está directamente
relacionada con la pandemia en general
hemos estimado que entre el 10 y el 15
por ciento de nuestros estudiantes se
encuentran en una situación económica
delicada hemos lanzado un llamado
público a la generosidad para subsidiar
le el alquiler a los estudiantes que
tienen más dificultades económicas
[Música]
estudiantes como óscar que no pueden
contar con el apoyo financiero de su
familia llegó de venezuela en septiembre
para integrar la escuela de ingenieros
artes y oficios y no tuvo tiempo para
hacer amigos sin embargo dice que no se
deprime
cuando se vive solo en un país diferente
con un idioma distinto y se tiene que
trabajar porque no se tienen los
recursos para pagar uno empieza a ver
todo de otra manera en la vida
completamente diferente el contexto
social allí en venezuela es totalmente
duro el contexto social la mozuela se
compraron yo así que creo que también ha
sido un entrenamiento para llegar aquí a
parís el hecho de haber soportado todas
esas experiencias
7 22
esta experiencia estampo cuando a buscar
a aferrarse a sus estudios y
especialmente a su sueño enviar a los
humanos a marte algún día